the red pill and men's Centric content
can I go first no
[Laughter]
I can go first
get familiar with all of the topics I'm
assuming like the stuff that you guys
talk about and consider the red pill
um it's not even like about like
disagreeing I think
you I can respect someone's point of
view and understand where that truth
exists for a lot of people and I just
feel like okay cool like I don't I don't
know I don't really disagree it's just a
perspective on life I'm not here to be
like you're wrong for thinking like that
you're wrong for categorizing using this
skill using that like it's a perspective
it's valid and I totally see certain
angles like there's a lot of stuff that
was said that I mean there's so many
people on this panel it's hard to talk
but it's like there's a lot of things
I've said okay maybe I don't agree with
just because again my Walk of Life and
what I've seen and how I feel and what
how I choose to be empathetic towards
people regardless of whatever they've
been through but I don't really it's
more for you it's the lack of empathy
sometimes yeah I think that's probably
it okay yeah
um I'm gonna let Esther go
no worries see what I don't really agree
with is the insult culture of men
feeling like they're entitled to a woman
a lot of men don't look good they don't
got money they don't do anything for
themselves and they expect women to want
to have sex with them women to want to
be with them why should she want to be
with you let me ask you a very important
why let me ask you a very important
question those delusional men
do they sleep with women
of course not okay but but they get
angry you see them in Pearl's comments
want you because you are a low life get
over it go to the gym go work on
yourself go out and get a job go and get
some money
that's how it is that's where most of
the men's Centric content tells guys to
do go to the gym get your money up like
that sort of thing learn game no but
that's not what they're doing what
they're doing is saying oh women are
delusional all women want this no why
women know what they want if you want
those women go and do what they want you
don't want and then you'll be chosen you
don't have to worry about the men that
aren't getting laid and all the women
are ignoring okay yeah YouTube comments
but besides YouTube comments they have
no voice in society and they don't exist
and nobody gives a [ __ ] right so this is
what I was saying earlier about about
reality slaps men in the face and shows
them their place very quickly because
all these men reality is showing them
their place there are women who are
disagreeable and unlikable and doing
wrong things and acting badly and
[ __ ] up how to make a man attracted
them and they're not being slapped in
the face by reality because they're
still ending up with a partner so this
is the point we're trying to make here I
agree I know what you're saying about
red pill there's a whole bunch of bitter
height-filled guys I agree with that yes
can I just drop another comment when I
came on your show they were in my DM
s little comments and then come into my
my social media and then just letting my
DMs like you really have nothing to do
without hitting on you or were they oh
no they were calling me some girls get
hit on even after the insults
because
we just don't want you but I get over it
that's just the internet though like I
get death threats I get like the luck on
something yeah people make videos it's
just I mean I just think like you go on
the internet duh like yeah you're gonna
get insulted on the internet
who hasn't been but it's obviously it's
quite hard especially when you're
receiving a lot of hate from all these
men I mean
I've had I've had hundreds of videos
made on Tick Tock like that go after my
appearance it happens to me like every
time
okay one one I called her a whale after
she attacked me after she she attacked
me she knocks the mic out of my hand she
called me a slack I didn't know what
that meant at the time okay I had no
idea what that meant she called me a
slag put the mic out of my so of course
I'm gonna call her will you you attacked
me first that's what they never talk
about you got called because you
attacked me I missed a good episode
it was a street interview and this girl
she like knocks the mic out of my hand
and they're pulling her back you I'll
have you used slag and I was like you're
effing female but it was like it was
like that was a response I've never
called someone on my show a whale
individually but when I come with you
I'll show you were quite rude to me
um I'm not gonna lie no I'm not gonna
lie the way you conduct your like show
today today was great but when I was on
your show last time you were like why
you talk too much I'm thinking who is
this woman talking to me like that I'm
not a child but that's the thing because
you kept interrupting everybody the
whole show no that's what happened
so today it's like we have we have a big
guest I'm gonna I'm gonna let him talk
but you're in no offense you're just a
normal guest and normal guest we don't
let dominate the entire conversation
you you you you were you probably talked
70 of the time and so I have to
interrupt you and stop you because
you're talking and nobody else in the
room and nobody else in the room had a
chance to talk I understand I interrupt
people but that's part of your job as a
host is to control the conversation and
if anything I probably control the
conversation less than I should compared
to most hosts no but I think it's the
way that you were rude you could just be
like okay let the next person talk you
were like why you talk to me that is so
weird because because
we had tried we had tried multiple times
to tell you nicely
multiple times to tell you nicely and it
just had to ask it just kept escalating
that is not true I think you're trying
to guess like me right now because
that's not true the thing is you didn't
agree what I was saying and then you
resulted you and Auntie resulted to
insults
but that's the reason I would say I'm
not coming for you right now because you
know what it's your show but what I'm
trying to say for us but we're not
coming for us no just open your mouth
listen what I'm trying to say what I'm
trying to say is
no how was I really why you called my
name into I was I rude to you but you
were rude how was Our Roots you were
rude this is this is just my point of
view you you told a story where you said
another you didn't say you're too nice
about it you'll find it too nice
I don't care right now because you went
on the streets
calm down don't tell me about calm down
hang on I had Mr Tate talking right with
passion right and loud I had no way time
to calm down right you're there shouting
off your mouth right I am very loud I am
being loud I don't tell me about calm
down because when he was talking who was
just screeching that listen right as far
as I'm concerned don't even think about
coming on per show and disrespecting her
you've done it already and now you're
coming back here to do it again Pearl
wasn't rude to you she was right that
wasn't rude to you yes you know what
because he spoke the truth
because at the end of the day it's all
out there if you don't know what a woman
is and you can't say what a woman
have some money
[Music]
okay all right guys let's take a second
to hear from our Channel sponsor
identity theft can be a nightmare
situation if it ever happens to you one
victim from San Francisco described her
experience after losing her wallet at a
bar apparently I stole a Tesla I got in
a car accident with it I got a new
iPhone I opened two new checking
accounts and went on a bad check writing
spree for as much as thirteen thousand
dollars at a time I attempted to open
dozens of new credit cards I wrote a
check for someone's bail which they
skipped and so on it took this victim
years and heavy amounts of stress to her
life to undo what the thieves did to her
if she would have had an identity
protection at the time she could have
mitigated some of the damage that the
thieves were able to do to her stories
like this are happening all over the
world and you have to be on high alert
to protect yourself one way to protect
yourself with identity from identity
theft is with virtual Shield one it
monitors banking retirement and
investment institutions for potential
data breaches dark web scans social
security protection with 24 7 alerts and
can protect you and your family with up
to a one million dollar insurance policy
virtual Shield one includes free access
to Virtual Shield's industry-leading VPN
with unlimited VPN access and advanced
VPN plus features to keep your internet
and cell browsing activity Anonymous and
private the service also includes
malware and ad blocking with a 30-day
free trial and 67 off this holiday
season what do you have to lose I use it
myself and love how it makes me feel
safe by protecting my identity and
keeping my browsing history Anonymous
just click the link below or simply
visit
www.virtualshield.com pearly that's
www.virtualshield.com pearly and protect
your identity today remember supporting
my sponsor supports this channel thank
you guys again I just think we're going
to see that situation differently I
don't think I was rude to you I actually
think I was quite polite but that's just
my opinion you think I was rude okay I
was just trying to explain why the women
came from
to be fair that was then you called me
racist and sexist
[Music]
let's go back to the topic your
disagreement with the red pill
oh so the insult you don't you don't
like the bad comments okay no no no no
not the bad comments the fact that they
just feel entitled when women say what
they want they feel so entitled that
women need to change that it's like no
women like what they like just like a a
man likes a woman that looks good A man
that a woman that cooks a woman that's
younger like he said someone that's not
been traumatized has not been through so
much experience like we don't cry about
it you know yes you know what we do you
know what women do yes yes wait wait I
need I need to stop you there yes we do
what is body positivity what is [ __ ]
shaming we do cry about it and we cry
about it loud on every social media
platform we do yeah there's no there's
no other way I'm just gonna give you an
equivalent there's no short man shaming
no you don't hear the man crying about
that
about it no they don't yes they do
there's you do you see a short man being
pushed to be on the cover of magazines
where they say we we need more short men
short short male models oh I see what
you mean where they're they're putting
plus-sized women on the cover of
magazines
I think I think he's like five eight to
five ten which is average actually like
most women don't know only 15 of men
over six foot yeah okay but I think
everyone
what they have like you know what if you
don't if you don't have money like own
it be happy with yourself
that's okay
I that it's fine I agree with you but
I'm saying like men have to deal with
the consequences like an average chick
can still sleep with an NBA player
who's like a top top 10. okay okay okay
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you an example okay I I've I've had guys
on that level message me I think I'm an
average chick I would never in my right
mind think that any of them would take
me like oh you're rich but but
what's your money men don't care about
you they know they don't they don't they
don't stop
she's from a rich background
okay men don't care about your money
care about your money
I personally don't like bumps that's
just not my thing that might be your
thing okay you want a high value matter
I'm not saying I value I'm saying I
don't I don't like guys that don't have
jobs just just just can I just say
something it's gonna shock everybody
I would like to hear what the novels got
to say now oh my days you know how much
I've been holding on to my feet like
what is it my turn to unleash everything
that's been in my head okay cool
question was again sorry what do you
disagree with from the red pill well I
disagree with the red pill movement is
the fact that it fails to understand
that it has extreme limitations because
you focus a lot on the extremities of
things and I will revert that back to me
I don't think the red pill addresses the
fact that there were a lot of housewives
that were left withered quite young and
therefore had no choice but to step up
in transition into a strong and evolved
Modern Woman and I say that because my
dad passed away when I was 12 and I
didn't have a man in my life to be able
to show me the way not only because
there's really just not many men in my
life because my mom focused her energies
and efforts into raising us and
providing for us because she didn't have
a man and I don't think it would be fair
to even expect my mom to when we were 12
13 14 to go and find a new man because
actually that creates even more issues
within the home first student to accept
him especially because we have close
relationship with my dad with that said
what the red pill movement fails to
address empathize with and look for
solution is for all the women and the
men that come from these sorts of homes
where actually it is not your fault that
you are a product of your environment so
when you were telling me about housewife
your masculine Edition that I have to
say my mom raised four daughters on her
own by my age she had the four of us
moved freshly to the UK of course she's
gonna hustle of course I'm gonna go
through education of course I'm gonna
work of course I'm gonna have to be
strong with myself because there's no
man to protect me so because I've had
this sort of background I've had this
sort of experience people tell me your
traumas are make you less likable or
maybe you're too masculine as someone no
I am a survivor of a woman actually
because I didn't have men around me and
I am actually again also capable of
being a wife I know how to cook I know
how to actually speak to my man please
him verbally and physically
so what's the distance
and I'll explain to you and I'll explain
to you submission side of things where
I've actually the whole show I've proved
that without having any friction with
undertake as much as you may even say
that may not be desirable enough I come
up with my own Solutions where I don't
have to compromise who I am but I can
still please you as a man you told me
your favorite car is that one even
though I let down I'm like do you know
what I like that one but looking at
yours you're just really nice too you
know I really like you got good taste
it's that simple what people explain
what people are failing to do with the
Red Bull movement is to understand that
that can be a compromise because I've
had to compromise my life as a woman to
be able to survive because I didn't have
a matter okay you think the red pill
doesn't agree with no believe in
compromise no it doesn't deal with the
victims of society of situations that
it's just life okay okay
um do you have any points for them both
of those yeah I can talk about the red
bill I can complain about it just too
too I think there is I I to be fair
um I do think there is a lot of Angry
Bear men which are attracted to it uh
and those are the ones that will leave
these stupid comments my point was that
but my point is that's they're they're
already being punished by God and by
Society so don't worry about it my point
is that if a woman doesn't act correctly
she doesn't feel the true sting of
punishment not in her prime years she
may feel it later but in her prime years
it doesn't [ __ ] even matter which is
why they do it whereas if a man doesn't
have a [ __ ] in order trust me he knows
very well because his realities sucks
and that's why he's sending you DMS
because he's lonely because if he had a
life he wouldn't bother right so there's
that part of it it does attract a lot of
angry bitter people but I think that's
because
life's very difficult as a man like we
said earlier and some of them end up
angry and bitter the answer to all
things I believe whether you're a man or
you're a woman to try and heal all Rifts
between the genders I think whether
you're a man or you're a woman the
answer to all things in life is to take
absolute not or self-accountability for
all the good and all the bad you must
look at yourself and realize everything
good that happened in your life is your
fault and everything bad that happens in
your life is completely your fault and
without having that high degree of
absolute accountability
it doesn't matter even if it rains
outside I blame myself because I didn't
have to be in London right I could have
gone I could have stayed in Dubai and it
wouldn't have rained so I'm responsible
for absolutely everything and if you do
that you pay attention to things and you
try your very best to mitigate the
negative circumstances and work your
hardest you're going to have a pretty
good life I just want to finish by
saying that I believe that men and women
are best as a team I don't think any
woman will be truly happy without a man
and I certainly know that no man will be
happy without a woman I think it's
absolutely beautiful we work as couples
and we create families and we stick to
our strengths when men stick to what
they're good at and a woman sticks to
what they're good at that makes them the
most powerful team on the planet
and the world we're living in now we
have societal pressures and propagandas
which are trying very hard to divide and
split the genders but truthfully the
power and the beauty of the universe
relies on us working together so
it's been very nice speaking to you
ladies I'm only upset that you ran out
of Clementines and I'm stuck I was going
to say give this man a knowledge and
this is my life there's melon out there
oh okay we've got melon but uh yeah all
in all I think it's I think it's good
and I I also think that discussion is
very very important and I think that a
lot of these issues are are delicate and
they're nuanced and people listening to
conversations like these and hearing the
different points of view and
understanding each other is a fantastic
way to progress and we're entering brand
new territory and it's never been done
before and perhaps you can call me
old-fashioned I don't think it's going
to be as good as it was in the olden
days but we're going to find out so uh
interesting
um okay thank you guys all for coming
we'll do a little round of applause for
the panel
um so why don't we go around and any
final thoughts any social media you want
to play as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible